c'est le grand jour
or or do maquis ses nouveaux élèves dans
la petite école de 5e une seule classe
dans le village pas d'inquiétude pour
les parents habitués ou rentrer la
troisième année qu'elle fait là donc
maintenant c'est un peu du
renouvellement comme tous les ans quoi
elle est bien habitués quoi elle est
très bien rentré les petites écoles
vivent encore dans nos campagnes ça fait
plaisir
difficile parfois de revenir aux classes
après deux mois de vacances mais pour
les 18 élèves de cm1 et cm2 la
transition se fait en douceur
j'aimais bien aller en vacances et mais
j'aime bien chez reprendre l'école parce
que ça fait longtemps quand la quitter
ça se passe bien mais pas tout le temps
après je retrouve plein de copains et
copines quand une de venir à l'école
parce que j'aime bien l'école lire
écrire travailler tous à la rentrée
c'est aussi le moment de reprendre
toutes les habitudes de découvrir le
programme de l'année et le
fonctionnement de la classe unique
donc moi vous me connaissez je suis la
maîtresse je suis la maîtresse aurore
déjà la mise en place par rapport à
comment on va faire comment ça se passe
dans la classe au niveau des cahiers des
livres niveau des classeurs qu'est ce
que la maîtresse attend de nous comment
est-ce qu'on va travailler qu est-ce qui
va y avoir comme travail à faire à la
maison les devoirs etc tout ça c'est
plein de petites choses comme ça qui les
inquiètent en général assez vite puis
c'est vrai que quand ils me connaissent
pas la maîtresse on la connaît pas
comment elle va est à ce qu'elle va être
gentil est ce qu'elle va être méchante
voilà il ya toujours cette appréhension
aussi quoi il pour dédramatiser le
moment les cm2 avaient même préparé une
chanson d'accueil pour leurs nouveaux
camarades
de quoi commencer l'année avec le
sourire